now thank you for joining us i'm john
langler and we are starting again this
afternoon with the weather the gusts
outside they've kind of died down but
boy are we in for a big warm up in a few
days sherry's here with a look ahead and
a look back at some of the winds we saw
yesterday sherry right john well we'll
get to that warm up here in just a
moment but want to show you some photos
that are very scary from a viewer up in
the northwest valley this is mary toomey
says that she brought her new car just
to the park she just bought it two days
ago she was taking her three-year-old
son to a play date in the alan beck
memorial park up at sky canyon park
drive and iron mountain road yesterday
when a huge gust of wind blew that iron
gate arm right into her car shattered
the roof and the windows she said if she
had a passenger in the front seat they
she really knows they would have been
killed so she was in the car her son was
in the back seat she ran and got her car
her son out of the back seat thankfully
they were ok but very shaken up as you
might imagine the damage was really
intense